Na Uzbillahimin Shaytana Raheem Bismillahir Rahmanir Raheem Alhamdulillah iladi la yabluqmidhatahul ka'iloon, wala yuhsina 'amaahul aaddoon, wala yuaddihaq kahul mujtahidoon, aladi la yudrikhu bardalhimam, wala yanaalu ghawsul fitan, aladi laisalisifatih haddun mahdudun, wala naatun maawjudun, wala waqtun maadudun, wala ajalun mamdudun.
Fatar al khala ikabi khudratihi wa na shara riyahabi rahmatihi wa wattadabis sukhuri madana ardihi wa salatu wa salamu ala sayed alam bi'i wal mursaleen khatim in nabiyin.
Sayedin al-mummadjad, Bashir al-musaddak, Nadir al-muayyad, al-Mustaf al-Amjad, Mahmood al-Ahmad, Abul Qasim Muhammad.
Wa salatu wa salamu ala wa see alibnabi Talib, Ashraf al-wasiyin wa amir al-mumineen.
Wa salat wassalamu ala sayyid nalimamit tayyib sahibid dawatin nabawiyya wa saulatul haydariyya wal Ismatul Fatimiyya wa shujaatul Husayniyya wa Ulum al Baqiriyya wal Ma'akil al Jaqiriyya wal Hikmatul Ismaailiyya wal Judul Muhammadiyya fasallallahu alayhim wa ala alayhim wa salaymuhum tasliman kathiran kathira
Allahumma la ilmalana illa ma alamtana inna kaantal alimul Hakeem Allahumma alimna bima yanfa'ana wa yanfa'ana bima alamtana Allahumma inna na'uzu bikamin al min la yanfa wa min qalbin la yaksha wa min aainin la tadma wa min nafsin la tashwaa Allahumma inna na'uzu bikamin daawatin la yusta jabulaha wa min munkaratil akhlaqi wa amal walahwa
Fa amma baadi akulu subhana wa ta'ala fi kitabihil kareem bada na foola audubillahi mina shaytana rajeen Bismillahir Rahmanir Raheem Rabbish Rahli sadri wa yaserli amri Wahlul qdatamil lisani yaf kahu kawli Allahumma thabitna aindil maawtibila ilaha illa Allahu Allahumma jaal na minaladina amanu waamila salihat wa tawasa wilhaq wa tawasa bisabr Amin ya rabbil alameen Once again assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu.
So, in the previous session, we looked at the linguistic meaning of the word Rab, right?
We learned that linguistically the word Rab is a combination of six attributes.
A Rabb is someone who is Malik who is
who has absolute ownership and at the same time he is Sayyid meaning he has complete authority over us and then within that space of complete ownership and unrestricted authority he is Murabbi he is the one who ensures growth right he takes care of his creation nurtures them protects them he is Murshad which means.
He not only nurtures His creation till they become mature, He then also sets them to purpose.
He sets each creation on the path of its destiny, and then He supports them through it.
And while doing so, He is also Muna'im, He showers His creation with numerous undeserved gifts and blessings.
And then finally He is Pa'yim, the one who sustains and maintains all of His creation for the extent of their duration.
So all these meanings come together to define the word Rab.
And we also learned that the primary ingredient in Allah's recipe of Rububiya is the ingredient of love.
All six meanings are grounded in that one fundamental emotion of Rahma, which is intense and constant love, care and concern for creation.
right and this is why we have Ar-Rahman wo Allam al-Quran right the intensely merciful taught the Quran that's what we learned it's not.
You know Al-Jabbar wo Allam al-Quran so Rahma is the most essential element of Allah's Rabbiya.
And this is why when we saw that journey of that person who was reflecting on the creations of the heavens and the earth, then naturally the word that came to him when he called out to his master was.
Rabb, right?
Rabbana.
Rabbana .
So he used the word Rab
because he saw all of creation reflecting the various attributes of his creator's Rububiya.
That's what he saw.
He saw creation reflecting the attributes of Allah's Rububiya.
And this is like, for example, if you meet a very skilled electrician, right?
If you see this guy working and just by observing his knowledge and his skill,
You can conclude that he actually went to a really good electrical engineering school, or at least he had some very skilled teacher who taught him this electric work.
Now you haven't actually seen the teacher, nor do you know the name of the school that he went to, but you are still able to conclude that just by observing his work.
How is that?
Because this electrician is his teacher's creation, you see.
and by his knowledge and his skill he is manifesting the attributes and the training of his teacher and this is exactly what creation is doing all of creation it is constantly manifesting the Rububiya of its creator and that principle holds true at a micro cosmic level and it certainly holds true at a macro cosmic level right that this universe
being a creation is constantly reflecting the attributes of its creator.
The seven heavens and the earth and everything that exists between them, they are all constantly glorifying Allah.
And there is not a thing in this world that does not sing His praise.
It's just that you do not understand their glorification.
It is you that do not understand their glorification, but everything else is in a constant state of glorification.
So in other words, the signs and ayat of who Allah is has been placed in the very fabric of His design.
And the more we reflect on creation, the more we will be able to appreciate the beauty of his desire.
So that is pretty much what we talked about so far, right?
So just to recap.
Now, in the last session, I said that Rab is commonly translated as Lord in English, but linguists agree that a more suitable one word replacement for Rab is actually master.
because a master not only represents ownership it doesn't just represent authority and control over something or someone it also represents perfection of knowledge and skill which is essential for nurturing for guidance for maintenance right so in the Arab linguists opinion the word master is much closer in meaning to the word Rab
than Lord okay so for moving forward whenever I want to use the English word for rub I will use the word rub I will use the English word master now once we understand the meaning of the word rub the next thing to understand is that the word rub it actually implies a relationship
There are certain words that just inherently imply relationships.
They need a counterpart.
So for example, when I say teacher, who does a teacher have a relationship with?
With students.
It automatically implies that relationship to exist.
I cannot be a teacher if I don't have any students to teach.
I cannot do the sessions if nobody attends the sessions.
So it's a two-way street.
When I say parent, what relationship is implied?
Children, right?
When I say employer, it implies a relationship with employees.
So there are certain titles that necessitate the existence of a relationship.
It doesn't work without
You know, the counterpart.
But when I say intelligent, it doesn't necessarily have any personal relationship with anyone.
Right?
It's generic.
When I say tall, it's a generic attribute.
It's not a personal relationship with someone.
Right?
So in the same way, Allah has certain attributes, certain names that do not necessarily imply a personal relationship.
For example, Allah is Al-Ala.
He is lofty.
Now that's a powerful attribute, but it's a generic state in relation to creation.
It does not imply a personal relationship, but then there are certain attributes which do establish relationship.
For example, Khalik, creator.
If he's a creator, there has to be what?
Makhluq, there has to be creation.
You cannot be a creator if you have no creation.
You can be powerful by yourself, you can be Alala on your own but not a Khalif until you have Makhloo, you understand?
Al Ghafoor is another one, Allah is extremely forgiving which means there has to be someone to forgive.
You know there has to be sin to exist otherwise forgive what?
So, there are some attributes of Allah that are generic in nature, and there are others that imply a very personal relationship.
Therefore, when Allah begins his revelation with the word Rab, which I briefly talked about in the last session, that when he introduced himself, when he said, Read in the name of your master who created you.
So, when he introduces himself as Rab to Rasool Allah and then by extension to us,
in doing so what he's essentially saying is that when you think of me I want you to put all my other attributes aside and I want you to think of me first and foremost as your Rabb right that's the whole idea behind introducing himself as Rabb
So he's saying that the one relationship that you should never let go of, even if you forget everything else, even if you forget every other relationship I have with you, the one relationship that you always need to be mindful of, every single waking moment of your life, what is that?
Rab.
That I am your Rab and my Rububiya will take precedence in all my dealings and interactions with you.
And the primary ingredient of my Rububiya is Rahma.
It is love, it is care, and it is concern for you.
But then what's interesting is that if you carefully observe the statement, he did not just say Rab, he said Rabbuka, your Rab.
I mean isn't Allah master of all creation?
right isn't he Malik Sayyad one who has absolute ownership and complete authority over everything so basically he could have just said to RasulAllah ...
read in the name of the master who created everything but no he makes it personal ...
read in the name of your master who created you right as if he's saying that I'm only your master and nobody else is
he's saying that he's only my master and nobody else is like when he deals with me he's gonna make it that personal as if he only created me and he's only my master and that applies to each and every you know human being in this world and so he makes his relationship that intimate with each and every one of us just as in as an introduction so SubhanAllah now does the relationship of Rab require a counterpart
It does, right?
If Allah is Rabb, you know, if Allah is Master, what does that make me?
And what does that make you?
What completes the relationship with a Master?
Slave, right?
If Allah is Master, that makes all of us slaves.
and the Arabic word for slave is abd.
So when we accept Allah as our Rabb just by virtue of us accepting that relationship, we are also accepting the fact that we are all His slaves.
Which is okay if you think about it.
Because you know we've already established that He's Malik, so He owns us.
We already accept that Allah has complete authority over us because He's Sayyid.
So we already know we are in submission to His training, His nurturing because He's Murabbi.
We know that we need His guidance because He's Murshad.
We know that we're constantly enjoying the countless undeserved gifts that He has bestowed upon us because He is Muna'im and we know that He is our ultimate sustainer and provider.
We believe that we exist because he allows us to exist because he's Qayyim.
So therefore it's not the most unimaginable thing to accept this notion that we are slaves to this gracious master.
And the truth is that whether we accept it or not, it really doesn't matter, does it?
I mean we are his property and we are his slaves regardless.
I mean, my children can fight with me and they can tell me, you know, we don't accept you as our father.
You are not our father from this day on.
And well, you know, tough luck.
Because guess what?
I am.
So you understand?
So we can reject it, we can deny being Allah's slave and everything, but by definition, we are property, so too bad.
so anyway I just wanted to set the stage by making sure everyone understands that you know our relationship that we are slaves of this master whether we like it or not and whether we want to accept it or not that that's just what the relationship is now having said that today what I want to actually show you is how beautiful this relationship is with this master because unless and until you appreciate the beauty of this relationship with him
we will not be able to reap the benefits of his rubbiya.
This is really important to understand because this is how relationship works.
Every relationship, you can think of any relationship.
A teacher cannot benefit a student until the student acknowledges and submits himself to the teacher, to the learnings of that, to the teachings of that teacher.
A student will only benefit from the teacher when he accepts that relationship and submits to it.
Right?
A doctor cannot help a patient until what?
Until the patient accepts and submits to the prescribed treatment of that doctor.
If a patient has diabetes, let's say, and the doctor is asking him to stop eating candy, but every time he sees candy he says,
oh you know I know the doctor asked me not to do it but what does he know anyway you know it's only a little bit I mean it's not like I'm eating the whole bag I mean he's never gonna find out anyway besides everyone else is eating candy so why can't I you know now if a patient does that he's not truly accepting the doctor-patient relationship is he I mean doesn't matter if he calls him if he addresses him as you know doctor so-and-so
It doesn't matter how many visits and appointments he keeps with that doctor, he's simply not going to benefit.
Why?
Because despite what he's saying, he is not really accepting himself as a patient.
Only after he completely accepts that relationship and submits to the doctor's treatment,
only then will he be able to gain the benefits that the doctor wants him to have.
So it's a two-way street.
Now this is what's really interesting that I want you to think about.
The doctor is completely helpless in this relationship until the patient completes that relationship, despite his vast knowledge and skill.
The doctor has the knowledge to benefit the patient
The doctor really cares about the patient.
He wants to benefit the patient.
But despite all of that, all of that knowledge, all that will, all that desire to help and benefit the patient, he is helpless.
He cannot do anything.
Why?
Because the patient has not yet completed the relationship, you see?
Now I'm not really talking about doctor and patients, am I?
We all claim that Allah is our Rabb.
We all know about His infinite Rahma.
We all know He wants the best for us.
We all know the treatment He has prescribed for our souls.
Right?
We all know the do's and don'ts.
We even pray and fulfill our religious obligations, but then in our daily lives we do everything that goes against His prescribed treatment.
So then how is our Rabb supposed to help and benefit us?
Isn't that interesting?
Despite the infinite powers of our Rabb, we render him helpless by not completing this relationship.
So if I truly want to gain the benefits that my Rabb has to offer, what do I need to do?
I need to complete the relationship.
Right?
And how do I complete the relationship?
By submitting myself as his awd.
This is how I can complete my relationship with him, you understand?
His relationship with me is that of Rubbiyya.
I complete that relationship with my Rubbiyya, with my Ibada, my submission, my servitude, and my worship.
So now let's understand this word ibada or obudiya properly.
The word ibada is generally translated as worship, which is an action.
And obudiya is servitude that acts as the driving force behind my various acts of worship.
You understand?
Ibada is my the various forms of worship.
Ubudiya is that feeling, that driving force of servitude that makes me execute those forms of worship.
Now what's interesting is that linguistically the word Ibada, it means two things.
It means Rubudiya Wattaa.
It means worship and it also means obedience both at the same time.
So let's break it down.
What is worship?
When we think of worship, what generally comes to mind?
The five prayers, right?
Fasting, Zakat, those things.
These are all different forms of worship.
And we think that's it.
We stop at those activities.
And that's the problem with this translation of the word ibada meaning just worship, because it does not necessarily include the concept of obedience.
The word ibada actually includes obedience and it's the kind of obedience that actually comes out of love, not force.
Because you know the word obedience can have a very negative connotation attached to it because people are forced into obedience, we know that.
Children are often bullied into obedience by the use of force or beatings or whatever, right?
Historically slaves have been beaten and tortured into obedience like animals.
So the word obedience can have a very negative emotion attached to it, but this is not the kind of forced obedience we are talking about here.
That would not be ibada.
The word for that kind of forced obedience in Arabic is Ritka which is equivalent to Ghulami in Urdu, right?
So
You understand the difference?
Rika is forced obedience.
Ubudiya is willing obedience.
Worship is actually a manifestation of that willing obedience.
So you know if you think about it the seven forms of worship that we know of right Wilaya, Pahara, Salat, Zakat, Haj Jihad these are all manifestations of willing obedience.
We do that because Allah has commanded us to do that.
So we execute all these various forms of worship in obedience to His command, right?
But if you are obeying willingly and happily, then you are in a state of Ubudiyya, which is the desired state.
If you are doing it with a grudge, if you're not actually happy to do it, you are in a state of Rika, which is not the desired state.
It's the same action, it's the same forms of worship.
I mean you're performing Salat in both cases but if you're praying unwillingly, you know if you're like...
you know if you're doing a hit-and-run Salat because you just want to get it over with, that is Rifka that is not Ibadah.
Ibadah is where you actually are willing, you want to do, you're looking forward to Ibadah.
That makes the difference.
So
When we talk about Ibada, always keep in mind that we're talking about willing obedience, we're not talking about forced obedience.
And therefore in the final analysis, Ibada is nothing but a willing obedience of the beloved generated from the emotion of passionate and unconditional love.
That is what Ibadah is.
It is a willing obedience of the beloved that comes from the emotion of unconditional love.
This is why when Imam Jafar Sadiq was asked: Ya Imam Halid Deen Oh Imam, what is the essence of religion?
It is nothing but obedience.
And then the man asked: Halit ta'ah What is obedience?
And he said: Ill al hub Nothing but love.
So, the essence of all forms of worship is willing obedience, and the essence of willing obedience is love.
You understand?
We learned in the previous sessions, earlier sessions, that Allah is Al-Ila, He is the Ila, right?
He is the one who takes precedence over all forms of Ila in our lives.
But what kind of relationship does He have with us?
He is Rab.
Right?
The word Allah describes who He is and what He is generally supposed to mean in our lives, but the word Rab describes a personal relationship with us.
In other words, He is the entity that is to be worshipped because He is Allah.
And he is also the entity that is to be willingly obeyed because he is a Rabb.
Right?
So to put this in practical terms, why are these two things important to understand?
Let's say we're about to go for prayers, right?
Let's say in 15 minutes it's time for Fajr.
And we have to do our Ibadah.
Now what kind of Ibadah is praying Fajr?
Is it worship or is it obedience?
It's worship, right?
But then from Fajr until Zohar, we may not be worshipping him, but what should we be doing at that time?
Obeying him.
You understand?
If we truly consider him an ilah and we truly accept his relationship with us as Rabb, then between two prayers,
You and I might not necessarily be worshipping him, but we still need to be in obedience to him.
This is why the concept of Ibadah is so comprehensive in Islam.
All forms of obedience are considered Ibadah in Islam.
Therefore if you really want to understand the word Ibadah, I prefer the word obedience over worship.
because unconditional willing obedience is worship unconditionally willing obedience is worship you go and earn a halal income at your job that's an act of ibada you go to school and sincerely accomplish the purpose of that learning that's ibada you obey love respect your parents and teachers that's ibada you are kind to your siblings
Generous to the needy, respectful to your elders, that's ibada.
You wash your hands before you eat, you cover your head before you go to the toilet, you smile at someone, you do wuzu before you sleep.
These are all acts of ibada because they are being done in the willing obedience and out of sincere love for the beloved.
So you can see how powerful the word ibada is in the Islamic terminology.
And it's an extremely comprehensive word, which is not just restricted to the forms of worship.
So I hope I made that clear.
So now that we understand the word ubudiya and this word ibada, let's understand abd, which means a slave.
Now what is a slave?
A lot of people, you know, kids and generally Muslims, even many that I have talked to, they take offense to this word slave because it creates a very negative image in their mind, right?
Based on how historically masters have treated slaves, the black slavery and then the, you know, the Jewish slavery and all that.
And fair enough.
so what I want to do today is use those same negative examples to draw out a comparison between the kind of masters we know or the kind of masters the world has seen and the kind of master our Rabbis and then you decide whether this word you know the word slave in the context of Islam is it an ugly word or a beautiful word I'll leave that up to you right so but but I think it's really important to look at this comparison because it really
gives us an idea of what we're talking about and what relationship we're actually trying to understand.
So let's begin with this term slave.
What is a slave?
What is the most defining characteristic of a slave?
A slave is someone who does not have free will.
That's the definition of a slave.
A slave does not have a choice in any decision that his master makes.
He must obey the will of his master without question.
In other words, a slave has no existence of his own other than fulfilling the desires of his master.
Isn't that true?
A master completely denies and prohibits free will for his slave, which is the ultimate form of humiliation.
Taking away an intelligent person's freedom of choice is the worst form of humiliation.
because it says I do not think you are capable of making the right choices it says I do not respect you enough to believe that you can make the right choice it says you are no different than an animal to me just as I choose and make decisions for my cattle and my dog I'm going to make your decisions for you
Denying the freedom of choice is the ultimate form of humiliation and disgrace for a human being.
We all know that.
Now when it comes to our Master, when it comes to our Rabb, what is the most precious gift that He gave us?
The ultimate gift that distinguishes us from all other creations in this world.
What is that?
It's free will.
Did he need to do that?
No, he is Malik, he's owner.
He's the owner of every single creation in this universe.
That fact alone makes every single creation his property, his slave, doesn't it?
We already established that.
That means being his property or his slave has nothing to do with being Muslim or not because everything is his property and slave.
The sun is his property, the moon is his property, the galaxies are his property, this entire universe and everything within it including you and I are his property.
Does the sun have free will?
Does the moon have free will?
Does the night and day have free will?
No.
They're all in complete submission to the will of their creator.
They're all floating in their orbits.
They're all bound by gravity.
They have no choice but to float in their orbits, right?
And Allah has bound them and taken away their freedom of choice.
We see that.
Could He have done that to us?
Could Allah have bound us?
Could Allah have forced us into submission?
Could the one who has compelled and enslaved the sun, the moon, the solar systems, the galaxies, could He have forced us into submission?
Absolutely.
But did He?
No.
He gave us an intellect and He gave us freedom of choice.
Something he did not give to any other creation.
The most powerful of creations he did not do that.
SubhanAllah.
So right off the bat we can see that indeed Allah is our master.
You know he is our Rabb but his Rububiya is unlike any other master we know of.
The very first thing every master we know of will try to do is take away our freedom of choice.
teachers, parents, bosses, judges, doctors, anyone, any worldly Rabb you can think of will try to control us by restricting our free will.
But Allah is the only Rabb who has granted us complete freedom of choice.
Now, we said that denying freedom of choice is the ultimate form of humiliation.
So my question is then, what is allowing complete freedom then?
If denying freedom is humiliation, then allowing complete freedom of choice is what?
It's the ultimate honor.
Subhanallah.
Allah honored us above and beyond every other creation by granting us freedom of choice.
and say that the truth has been revealed by your master whoever chooses let him believe and whoever chooses let him disbelieve complete freedom of choice now what kind of gifts do master give their slaves nothing right they barely feed them they barely clothe them they barely pay them
And when they do feed and clothe them, they give them the bare minimum, just enough to keep them alive, right?
And for the very little they give them, how much do they expect back in return?
A lot! Every master we know of gives the bare minimum and expects the maximum from his slaves, right?
What has Allah given us?
We talked about the numerous undeserved gifts that the Muna'im has showered upon his creation right.
Precious gifts that are above and beyond the reason and any logic of economics.
Any company that gives its employees this much the way Allah gives us that company would just bleed red.
Now in comparison to the quantity and the quality of the gifts that our Rabb bestowed upon us
How much does he expect in return?
The bare minimum.
The very least.
SubhanAllah.
I mean, of all his creations, our Master gave us the most.
Right?
The rest of creation is constantly in a state of abudhiya to him.
They're all working round the clock in constant obedience to Allah without taking a moment's break.
But then despite giving us the most, he expects the least from us in return.
I mean what is Salat?
Count the entire Salat during the day what?
One hour?
One month of fasting out of 12?
That too only from sunrise to sunset?
Two and a half percent of wealth in Zakat?
The wealth that he gave us in the first place.
Incredible!
and even then you miss salat no problem do qaza you cannot find water no problem do tayammum you're sick traveling no problem do your fast later on you don't have a saving that has been left untouched for a year no problem no zakat for you you don't have to pay zakat you don't have money for hajj traveling is not safe no problem I'll lift your obligation of hajj from your shoulders I mean this is crazy
How easy has he made it for us?
And what kind of master does that?
Do you know of any master in the world who would make it that easy for his slave?
Do you know of any other master in this world who will give so much and ask for so little in return?
Subhanallah, we've never heard of such a master.
On top of that, right, if that wasn't generous enough,
He then sent us revelation and messengers to explain his reasons to us.
Why you should do this?
Does a master ever ever ever explain his reasons to his slaves?
Can any slave turn to his master and say hey explain the purpose of this command to me?
Can a slave negotiate with his master?
Can a slave say you know I'll obey your command only if and when you explain it to me?
Can any slave do that?
No.
But did this master explain things to us in the Quran?
Did this master through the life example of Rasul Allah sallallahu alaihi wasallam show us how to practically execute our obligations?
Did this master make it compulsory, mandatory on us to understand before we do something?
Did this master make it actually obligatory on us to understand the reasons of his command?
SubhanAllah! Why would he do that?
No master ever does that.
He did that to make it easy for us to accept his relationship.
To make Ubudiyya easy for us.
Yuridu Allahu bikumul Yasr, Walaa yuridu bikumul Usr.
Allah desires ease for you.
He does not desire hardship for you.
Now here's another question.
Who are the acts of worship meant to benefit?
Who is slavery always designed to benefit?
The master or the slave?
Always the master.
But this master, He designed the universe for us, He gave us the most,
He asked the least in return from us.
He explained the reasons of His command to us.
But the question is everything He asked us to do, who does it benefit?
It benefits us and only us, SubhanAllah.
Every slave in the world is bought and put to work to benefit the master.
Every command issued to a slave is for the master's benefit.
So what kind of a master is this whose every single command is meant for the benefit of his slaves?
Not one single command for his own benefit.
If that is not love, if that is not care, if that is not rahma, if that is not ease, if that is not mercy, then you tell me what is.
Allahu Akbar.
He is in constant service to us and what he asks from us in return is also to benefit us, not him.
Is the work of a slave judged according to the capabilities of the slave or according to the expectations of the master?
A slave's work is always judged according to the level of the master standards and expectations.
How does Allah judge our actions?
According to our individual level of knowledge and capabilities.
Nowhere in the entire Quran does Allah demand perfection.
Nowhere, not a single place.
The only thing He asks for in the Quran is effort and sincerity.
That's it.
Who does that?
What kind of a master does that?
Do you know of any master in this world that rushes to fulfill the needs of his slaves?
Do you know anyone like that?
Have you ever watched a movie, read a book in which a slave calls out to his master in need and the message just drops everything and runs to his aid?
Do you know of any Rabb like that?
But what does Arrab do?
When my slave...
Look at that, My slave, when my slave asks, he's telling Rasool Allah this, he's saying when my slave asks you about me, I am near him in that very moment.
I immediately respond to the call of my supplicant when he calls upon me, immediately...
the moment he calls me.
No master ever does that.
From what history tells us, slaves are always rushed to fulfill the needs of their masters, never the other way around.
So then what kind of...
Master is this?
What kind of a merciful master is this who rushes to fulfill the needs of his slaves?
Who rushes on the call of his slaves?
So the more we reflect upon the Rububiya of our master, the more we realize that His Rahma, His mercy is absolutely incredible.
We find that he is extremely loving, extremely caring, extremely merciful.
He's unlike any other master that we know of.
He's unlike any other master we will ever come to know of.
No master does for his slave what our Rab does for us.
But the problem is that because he is so subtle in his love and mercy that we forget our place.
we forget that we are property we forget that he is Malik he is owner because if he's owner then that just by that definition that makes me property which means he can do whatever he wants with me he can break me he can rip me apart he can burn me drown me he can do whatever he wants with me and when he chooses to do that there is absolutely nothing that I can do or you can do or all of us put together can do
or everything in the universe combined can do to protect me against that wrath.
If the Rahman decides to harm me, there is absolutely nothing in existence that will be able to help me.
But even look at that, right?
If the Rahman decides to harm you, SubhanAllah.
Not in Yuridin al-Jabbar, in Yuridin al-Qahar, in Yuridin al-Zuntiqam, right?
If the conqueror, if the powerful, if the avenger decides to harm you, no, no, no, no.
In Yuridin al-Rahman, if the Rahman decides to harm you, even in his dur, even in his harm, he is merciful.
even in his affliction that he puts on us even in that there is a hidden benefit subhanAllah look at the words he uses and yet we constantly disobey him we constantly fail in our in our obedience and servitude to him but he still allows us to exist I mean how grateful should we just be for that
Just think about that.
You know my phone?
It was causing problems.
It was acting up.
It was freezing up.
I had to restart it every now and then, right?
You know what I did?
I went to the store.
I got a new phone.
I got rid of the old one.
Why?
Because occasionally, not all the time, occasionally a few times it acted up on me, so I got rid of it.
Because that's what we do with property that is no longer doing its job.
We discard it.
We are all Allah's property and we are not doing our jobs.
Not occasionally, not sometimes, in some cases constantly, all the time.
So now what should my owner do with me?
Now, what should my owner do with such a useless property as myself?
Discard it.
But does he do that?
Allahu Akbar.
I mean, how grateful should we be just for that?
So you can see that even though words such as, you know, Rab and Abd, master and slave are used, he is unlike any other master we can imagine in this world.
This is a master who loves us intensely, constantly.
And so when we realize, when we realize that, what is our natural response to him?
To love him back.
And this is yet another unique relationship if you think about it.
There is not a single master in this world where a slave would love his master.
In fact, historically, slaves have always hated their masters.
The first chance they get, they want to run away from their masters.
Isn't that true?
But we wholeheartedly love our master.
And so the only direction that we want to run in is towards him, not away from him.
And how do we do that?
By submitting ourselves to his love and mercy through our willing obedience.
Not a forced obedience as we experience in the world, a willing obedience.
An obedience that is based on the highest stages of love that we learned earlier.
An obedience that manifests in the desire of service and servitude.
Like the service of a passionate lover, an ashaq for his mashuq, for his beloved, right?
That is Abu Diya, that is worship.
And therein lies our greatest challenge.
Now listen to this carefully, I'm going to wrap up.
The greatest challenge, the greatest difficulty, the greatest hardship that you and I constantly face in life, every single waking moment is to accept Allah as Rabb.
I'll say that again.
The greatest and constant challenge you and I and everyone else in this world faces is not accepting our creator as Allah.
Everyone is fine with that part, right?
Even the Jahiri Arab, they accepted him as Allah.
There is no one in this world, there's no one in this group here that has a problem with accepting him as Allah.
We all believe he's Allah.
The real problem, the real challenge is in accepting him as Rab, as Master.
You know why?
Because if you accept him as Rab, if I accept him as Rab, that means we become what?
We have to become his slaves.
We have to accept his relationship.
We have to give up our freedoms of our passions and our desires and to put the collar of his Ubudia around our necks and become his slaves.
And that is where we all struggle.
because we all live in times of absolute and unrestricted self-indulgence we live in the times where I am in charge I am control you know I am the master of my own destiny I am powerful I am wealthy I don't have to listen to you you're not the boss of me I can do whatever the hell I want whenever I want you know I'm the king of my domain this is my life
if I want to do it I'll do it if I don't want to do it I won't in other words I am my own Rabb I am my own master and Allah is saying no I am your master I gave you this life I gave you this authority I gave you these gifts of parents I gave you these gifts of children you know I honored you with intellect and free will
I gave you position and power I gave you health, wealth, strength I gave you all these things so that you could recognize me and come closer to me because I am your master but I am a master who is unlike any other master you will ever come to know of so submit to me with willing obedience and I will show you what true happiness is
Willing and happily accepting our ubhudiya and submitting to our Master in sincere obedience and true worship is the greatest challenge that you and I will ever face in our lives.
And the only way to overcome this challenge is by recognizing and appreciating the love and mercy of our Master.
and by completing the relationship of Abu Diya through a willing submission and obedience to our magnificent master because love engenders love right and if this incredible Rab if this incredible master does so much for us disobedient and ungrateful slaves what would he do if we actually did become willingly obedient right that's something to think about
Wa is ta azana rabbukum la in shakartum la azidan nakum.
Wa la in kafartum in na adabi la shadeed.
And your master said, if you become grateful, I will give you more.
La in shakartum la azidan nakum.
If you become grateful, I will give you more.
Wa la in kafartum in na adabi la shadeed.
But if you become ungrateful, then indeed my punishment is severe.
right, so may Allah give us all the knowledge, the willingness, the capability to recognize His love, to move towards.
Him in complete submission and you know be a good slave to this gracious master...
Okay, so we have a couple of questions.
Okay, so the first question is, if our relationship with Allah is of master and slave, then what is the concept of freedom in Islam?
Well, that's an interesting question.
What is freedom?
Right?
In Arabic, freedom is very different from, you know, in Arabic freedom is different from the definition of how we look at freedom in modern English, right?
So for instance, freedom in the pre-Islamic culture, right, the word hur, which means, you know, a free man, the word hur was in contradistinction to an awd, a slave.
In other words, a free person was somebody who was not an Abd.
So the pre-Islamic people, they had the Hurk, which is the free man, and then the Abd, which is the slave.
Now, one of the most amazing things about Islam is that it makes you Abdullah.
Right?
It makes you Abdullah, it makes you slave of Allah.
Now, if you are Abdullah,
If you are the slave of Allah, then what does that make you in relationship to everything else?
It makes you free.
Right?
Because now your ubudiya, your obedience and your servitude is only to Allah.
It is not to anything or anyone else.
And so it sets you completely free.
So the Hur, right?
So the Arab says
He says ...
The free man is a slave as long as he is covetous, as long as he is greedy, as long as he has wants and desires.
And the slave is a free man if he is content.
Right?
So, a free man is a slave as long as he is covetous
And the slave is a free man if he is content, which gets to the essence of the Arab understanding of freedom before Islam.
That freedom in reality is moral freedom.
It's a freedom from want.
It's not a freedom to.
See, in our culture, freedom has been almost entirely defined by freedom to.
Freedom to do whatever I want.
Freedom to say whatever I want.
Freedom to have whatever I want, right?
So it's all about freedom to for us.
But to the Adams, it was freedom from.
Freedom from desires, freedom from wants, freedom from needs.
They saw all of these things as shackles.
That's how they perceive freedom.
So the Islamic concept of freedom comes from that powerful paradigm.
Enslave yourself to the one to free yourself from everything else.
Or move away from the one and become a slave of everything else.
And you know when we talk about enslaving oneself to Allah, it's essentially just accepting that relationship of Rabul Biya, right?
Because we are slaves regardless, we already established that.
We are property regardless of whether we accept it or not.
So the concept of freedom is essentially just recognizing that relationship and drawing towards him and in that process we achieve complete freedom and happiness.
So I hope that answers the question.
Here's the next one.
If Allah is so merciful, then why did Imam Hussain and his friends suffer in Karbala?
Well, you're saying why did Imam Hussain and his friends suffer in Karbala?
I mean, that's a matter of perspective, isn't it?
Did they really suffer?
I mean, yes, apparently, you know, from how things played out, sure.
But if you think about suffering, I mean, what are some of the signs of when somebody is in a state of suffering, what are some of the signs?
Fear, right?
Regret, depression, always trying to escape.
When we look at Imam Hussain and his companions,
What do we find?
Was there fear?
No.
Absolutely no fear.
Were there any regrets?
No.
They couldn't wait to die.
Was there depression?
Historically we find out that these people were actually they went to the battleground smiling.
The only reason the only times when they were depressed according to the stories that we read about Karbala
I'm sure if you've read the stories you would agree to that anytime they were depressed was when Imam Hussein did not give them permission to go out in battle That's when they would cry and they would they would get depressed and they would be sad and they would plead with the Imam to say that please let me go that What was his name?
that John that black slave
right he said yeah Imam you don't want me to when he went to Imam Hussain and he asked permission to go out in the battlefield Imam Hussain said that look you're a slave and you have completed your servitude to us and I free you now you are not obligated to do this for me you're not obligated to kill you know martyr yourself for me that's what he says to him and the slave John he starts crying and he says yeah Imam
You do not want a black man to lay amongst the white people.
You are all white and you are all you know your skin is white and shiny and I am dark and I am black and you just don't want a black person to die along with white people and you don't want my smelly sweat to mix in with the fragrance of your people.
I mean, you know, if he was suffering, he should have jumped at that opportunity.
He should have run away.
I mean, he actually played the racist card.
You know that the child that comes to the mother at the camp when she sends out her son, who just recently got married, she sends him out in the battleground and she says that, you know, do not
do not become a coward and do not shy away from you know becoming a martyr and go and martyr yourself on Imam Hussain.
He goes out and then he fights and he comes back and he's all completely you know drenched in his own blood and he comes back to his mother and he says you know mother are you happy with me now and she says no.
She says not until you sacrifice yourself for Imam Hussain.
I mean if this was suffering why would she say that?
I mean Karbala in my opinion is the prime example of Ubudiya.
It was a battle to defend the honor of the beloved.
That's what Karbala is to me.
It's a battle to defend the honor of the beloved.
Yazid is you know he's this guy who has challenged the Rububiya and the Ilahiya of Imam Hussain's beloved.
And for the companions he is somebody who has challenged imamate of their beloved.
And so he and his friends they stood ground to defend the honor of their beloved and to set an example of true love for all of us.
They showed us that this is how you love.
you pay any price you pay any cost for your beloved you sacrifice your food your drink your children your family even your own life but you do not desert the beloved because what kind of love is it that flees at the first sign of trouble right and for a true lover what good is life anyway without the beloved's grace right
Falaita ka tahlu wal khayaatu mariratun, walaita ka tarda wal anamu ghidabu, walaitalladi baini wabaina kaamirun, wabaini wabaina lalamina kharabu, fayaalaita shurbi min widadi kasafiyan, wa shurbi min ma'il-farati sarabu ida nil tumin kal wuddha fakullu hayinan, fwakullalladi fau katurabi turabu.
If I could just taste the sweetness of your happiness, the poet says, If I could just taste the sweetness of your happiness, it wouldn't matter if life becomes bitter for me.
If you are happy with me, who cares about the anger and the wrath of the world?
you know may things remain beautiful between us and let the entire world become ugly for me you know a sip from the wine of your love even makes the sweet water of Euphrates like a mirage for me
all I need is your love if I have that I have everything otherwise even the greatest treasures of this world is just dust for me so anyway so so yeah I think that you know you're looking at it the wrong way
That was not suffering, what we see in Karbala.
That's just an expression of immense love.